uh yeah so um with our electronic
challenges here uh today it's a pleasure
to welcome Michael glinsky um many of
whom uh at least in the plasma physics
world at the lab know him um um he um
has a 30-year career focused on data
science deep learning basy and data
analysis which is going to be very
popular with our crew I guarantee worked
in uh Laboratories like ours but also
companies like Royal Dutch sh BHB
halberton the list goes on llnl Sandia
faculty member um in the physics
department of Western Australia um again
going back to um some of our laser
interaction uh Community here was a key
member of the team that founded in vasic
um an Nea lead investor firm um aiming
at laser treatments for ES schic stroke
uh in terms of your deep dark past um
you got your PhD from UCSD in physics
and INF facted post-doctoral work here
uh on ICF and um Mike is currently the
CEO of bnz Energy Incorporated um uh
which described here is a disruptive
investment in operating company for the
energy transition powered by AI risk
management um the um I just just want to
say before I give the title of this talk
and and turn things over to him is uh we
have a fairly flexible schedule today if
people want to come by and um and talk
to Mike he will we've changed the room
he will be in building 481 but um on um
in room 2117 which is uh I think that
the old mit guest office um and then um
with that um I'll turn this over to Mike
who's going to talk about a
physics-based reduced order model
capturing the topology of dynamic
manifolds uh I will leave it to
you okay um thanks very much Steve and U
that uh you know this work uh really
started uh with probably back in about
2011 uh when I ended up seeing Stefan
mot uh talk first about his deep uh
convolutional uh transformation called
the scattering
transform and that uh when I saw it
initially I saw a lot of things that
started ringing bells in terms of
quantum field theory in my mind
uh there you know he was talking about
Vic ordering uh path ordering type
things in there uh also uh there you
know were just also other things ringing
in the back of my head with respect to
renormalization group too associated
with it uh also it seemed to have some
connection also in my mind to verer
Heisenberg's uh s Matrix and the
scattering Matrix in fact he called it
the scattering transform because I was
talking about the S Matrix and even the
name ended up coming from some of my ear
because I've actually been a
collaborator of Stefan
mot uh that dates back to probably the
early
2000s and uh one of the first we
actually deployed ing dei's proximal
gradient uh methods even before it was
published in terms of Spar by conversion
for um or Decon solution
for uh seismic data and I mean it works
spectacularly well as it has in many of
the other areas of data
science and uh but I struggled with this
for a decade and actually over a decade
about trying to understand the
relationships there were different
attempts that I made at it uh you know
and but it just really never hit but the
one thing that I realized along the way
was that it was performing extremely
well and that in terms of being able to
crack problems that hadn't been cracked
before uh things in terms of texture
recognition where people were you know
had very poor maybe 20% miscal you know
misclassifications when they ended up
going using this taking the logarithm of
it and then using just simple linear
discrimination methods they were getting
performance which were state of art of
less than 5%
misclassification and so I kept on
scratching my head too I mean associated
with that and then also I me I went and
uh had been talking also with John Field
who had been working at this laboratory
at the time and he kept on going and
saying hey does this have something to
do or in terms of artificial
intelligence with topology right and
some type of topological dis uh uh type
of of
analysis and um uh you know you know
fortunately since I've left uh San die
National Laboratory and founded this
company and we were in the startup phase
of it that uh I had the ability to
really sit up my you know put up my feet
on my front porch have good morning
coffees and really think profoundly
about this stuff and I never really had
that luxury before and what I'm going to
go and present here is uh that is based
off of some work I did under contract
with sanyia after I left there and that
I really tried some stuff and it worked
spectacularly well in terms of a
workflow and then subsequent to that and
I'll talk a little bit about the the
scientific exploration method that you
know I ended up going through that I
ended up going and I think really
cracking the nut on on this right and
that it's actually this is a slide I put
together uh this morning and that um
that it's not changing actually is there
a
problem with that okay okay it's just
taking a while to go through that um you
know this is actually going and is
challenging a lot of paradigms right and
that I mean I think that even uh
ourselves that we don't realize that
things like quantum mechanics actually
actually have gone from a critically
developed Theory to a matter of Paradigm
or dogma of where we go and recite
things without really thinking
critically about it and here I'm going
to be going and taking a look at uh uh
artificial intelligence and to think
critically about something you know I
was taught in terms of leadership uh
Executive coaching that you really need
to go and start asking yourselves
questions right and I want to go and I
don't expect you to answer right but as
I go through the talk in this
exploration is to go and start thinking
critically about what we're doing in
artificial intelligence right and that
uh these were questions that I ended up
going and asking myself as I was going
and developing this stuff right okay
first of all what are the variables when
we have these nodes and reduced order
models right because if you go and take
a look at the architectures that tend to
be successful they have bottlenecks
right in terms of uh their structure
right uh whether or not that be
autoencoders okay and I'll be talking
about some of those specific structures
here whether or not they be unet
structures right uh whether or not they
be you know things like you know based
off of David Silver's deep uh rein
enforcement learning
dqn uh or whether or not they be gpts
right these things all have choke points
in it right where they're forcing the
fit right to actually find some type of
reduced order model in terms of those
limited nodes at the choke points right
what are those things right and in the
context of deep reinforcement learning
in uh uh you know Q learning that um if
you go and look at the feature value
iteration right they have these thetas
right okay and that uh that things are
not truly done that way but you'll go
and see what are Theta right in there
right and you know I was sort of taught
in my you know grad course on artificial
intelligence at carnegi melon that you
could choose anything I mean I don't
think there's a statement that could be
farther from the truth right right there
are very specific things that you need
what what those are and you'll see me go
and and and actually answer this
question right and then also if you go
and you have all these deep
convolutional networks right these are
functional Transformations right going
from a function space to a function
space right from a hillbo space to a
Hilbert space well that's a Bono space
right we're searching a Bono space right
well that's like impossible right okay
um and so what do we have to do we
always make really constraining
assumptions about the form of that
functional
transformation even then we can be left
with a billion parameters so we have
regularization techniques to go and
further reduce the number of actual
independent parameters in the model so
that we can fit it with a finite number
maybe 10,000 samples or something of
that nature
right and but our brain like comes
pre-programmed with this right we don't
go and have to do anything right it's
evolved to have a very particular
convolutional Network structure right so
ask yourself the question why do we
spend tens of millions of dollars
learning what these structures are on on
a Case by case basis right okay I mean
you know I like our brain just comes
that way right I mean I think that you
realize well we transfer learn a lot
well yeah I mean you're learning this
probably the structure of this deep
convolutional Network right and so you
know and then an Associated question is
what is the Deep convolutional or
functional transformation doing right
you know and I really started you know
those were my introspection questions
about what we're doing it needs to make
some sense right now I have the sort of
cheeky question what is Q learning right
okay I mean that is what is Q right you
know when you're doing deep Q learning
what is the Q function
right okay think about it right okay and
then you know John Field's question
right and which was a real proposal by
him is artificial intelligence related
to the topology and geometry of the
system's Dynam dynamical manifold right
are we learning what the homology class
is of the of the topology are we
learning about what those singularities
are right
okay um I don't know maybe
okay the next one okay is there a
physical justification for rectified
linear units right I mean you know from
the early parts of my career that neural
networks were not very successful
multi-layer perceptrons weren't really
successful the Advent of the rectified
linear unit was like Nirvana was reached
right when you put those things on there
right why I mean why you know I mean you
know is there a physical justification
for why you're using rectified linear
units right the next thing is why is the
logarithm so important right okay you
know that uh this may not be I think uh
but you it seems to be you want to throw
logarithmic transforms on things to make
them work right okay and it's very
explicit in what Stefon malot did with
the scattering transformation one thing
he actually even buries on and sometimes
doesn't even tell you is he always takes
the logarithm of it right and in my uh
work that I did based off of Gorgon I
always had I had to take the logarithm
before as well as after right okay and
actually I should have been taking it in
between too but that was a little bit
hard to do because Stefan never embedded
that in his transformation right and
like then everything's linear like what
huh okay uh you know linear methods work
you know and they work as well as
anything right and and they have
fantastic performance right and then
also uh and this goes to I don't know uh
people that have been out there and have
had interactions with bados off
aan but he's been talking about stud
pulses right and he's been doing that
you know talking about it for quite a
while right
well that you know go and think a bit is
there an equivalent of ponder mode of
stabilization in deep reinforcement
learning right and is that what bedros
is talking about with respect to stud
pulses right when I hear him give those
talks I started having a lot of op
Ponder motive stabilization type
thoughts associated with it right and
can we do something like that right and
with that said let me go and jump into
my slide of equations right and that uh
after this uh this is the one slide of
equations um I'm going to walk you
through just what the steps are okay
here uh but the thing that I'm going to
go and want to get uh and show you in
the end and the magic thing is this
recursion relation okay and you can see
the recursion relation has it's a layer
of a convolutional network okay in this
case with a set of scaled wavelets okay
it's a scaled wavelet transformation
where p is the scale of the wavelet
transformation and then it has a
activation or a rectifier okay and that
because this is now going to go and be a
it's a recursion relation
that you can go up and get to the m
order Thing by applying the uh recursion
relation M times so we end up with a
convolutional deconvolutional
network where the layers are the you
know each time that we apply it in the
product so it will have little M layers
associated with it right where this
actually is what you normally would go
and use a realu for okay but instead
okay you actually have I because it's
complex
transformation you have a
logarithm and R KN basically gives you 1
plus X so that when you take the
logarithm of 1 plus x and x is small
that you end up finding that for small X
actually log x equals X and since we're
going to be going and applying this
again and again if we don't have that
property you actually see it blows up
right okay so for
convergence uh me reasons you need to go
and have that in there right okay and so
how do we go and get to this formula
okay and I will go and talk about the
gray box after I get the uh one to go
and relate it to what the normal
rectifiers are are that we end up using
right and so let's just talk start with
a normal tailor expansion of a complex
function okay and that the tailor
expansion coefficients okay are just
obviously the derivatives okay of
whatever that function is and that uh
this is also though go and I will go and
realize these are the SM Matrix okay uh
in terms of what the N particle
scattering coefficients are I will
assume that H subm is actually a
functional of the fields and the co-
momentums of the fields okay I Define a
convolutional wavelet
transform okay uh here the standard
definition of a wavelet
transform I consider an analytic
trajectory which is parameterized by X
that's nothing more than the
convolution okay of uh the wavelet with
that I take the co- Vector along the
trajectory by taking D of that I changed
the radial coordinates about zot which
is a little bit of a uh inspiration at
this point so I actually get the
property at the end and took a little
bit of fiddling as you may uh expect I
rotate by pi over two to get the co-
vector by multiplying by I and so I find
that DH subm is equal to D of I log Z
okay and then with this simple
definition of what R the rot function is
it's a analytic function I end up going
and getting what the recursion relation
is right but this is a logarithmic
generating function of a complex
hamiltonian right and okay complex
hamiltonian what okay well that the real
part of the hamiltonian is the
hamiltonian that we go know and love
right and so you go and you specify that
and what's the imaginary part well you
actually don't have any freedom there is
a complex analytic continuation of that
uh and of the real part of the
hamiltonian so you get the complex part
as just the the natural analytic
continuation of it right but also that
normally if you go and take a look at
Quantum field Theory you always deal
with respect to exponential generating
functionals right e to the generator of
e to the I right but by taking the
logarithm you actually get a generating
function of directly of the
hamiltonian and that's also the reason
why the logarithm is being introduced
inside of it right okay and now let me
talk a little bit about what this
activation function or what the
rectifier is here right think a little
bit back into your days of complex
analysis about what is the complex
logarithm right okay the complex
logarithm the real part of it is the
natural logarithm of the modulus
okay and that the argument the imaginary
part of it is the phase or the argument
of the complex number right okay so that
uh if you now go and first of all take
take a look at log of R KN as Z goes to
zero okay it goes to the identity so we
don't have problems it's a compact
mapping okay is what that basically
says and then if I now go and take Z
going to Infinity I actually go and find
that it goes to log modulus right well
the scattering transformation has the
log has the modulus in it so if I take
log of the scattering transformation
okay I'm and also take the log of the
signal take the scattering
transformation of it you know the first
order then take the log of it I've
actually you know gone to things in this
limit right okay and it actually should
be in between every step of the deep
convolutional Network just not at the
end but log of log is log after you do
log two times basically it is can I
question sorry um coming from my
ignorance uh so is what's going on here
is we have a set of dynamical variables
that we're going to try to use to much
more efficiently describe I think in
your case it's going to be a pulse power
thing or something like that and there's
there's a kind of an equation of motion
for that that comes from you know
whatever the original equation was and
so is what you're doing telling us how
so there's a hamiltonian that evolves
that system there's a Hamilton jacobe
equation in those funny variables so the
partial differential equation which is
my my problem is what you're describing
here a or going to be a transformation
of the variables in which you describe
that that system making it more
efficient I'm putting words in your
mouth but there you go well have I got
it yeah yeah yes okay but let me just go
and I'll I'll give you the answer you're
asking for what the answer is right okay
I mean right now I'm developing and
answering the question why log right
okay um but what you what is actually
what what's happening all right Steve is
that you are going from the field basis
right okay and you're going into a
renormalization basis where it's a basis
where that each one of you'll find that
there are a certain number of spectrums
complex spectrums right okay and you're
decomposing into each one of those
complex spectrums right and so you're
going and say if you have a complex
Spectrum beta of frequency right and
phase that now you go into and you
project the motion is going to lie on a
hyper plane which is the projection into
the renormalization basis right so
you've gone from motion on a hillberg
space in the deeply convoluted field
domain and you've actually exposed a
small number of dynamical PS and q's by
actually projecting onto the the
solution of the renormalization group
equations right okay and then it becomes
a simple matter of finding out what the
solutions are to the Hamilton jacobe
equation right in that domain so why is
um why is I mean so so the original
variables and mutations of them come
from a you know rad Hydro or some or
pulse power some field yeah yeah so why
is there a Hilbert space here what's
that about because I mean it comes about
because you actually have a function of
position right fields are something that
are defined as a function of positions
they're actually functions right okay
and so that you're actually seeing how
functions actually are transformed with
time and so the basic instead of having
a finite number of keys and cues right
okay you actually have something that's
actually a full function which is an
element it's continuous function that's
an element of a hird space right and so
that whenever you deal with field
equations you're going and that the
you're you are dealing with something
that's actually fundamentally an
evolution of a function rather than an
evolution of a certain number of
discrete variables
right um well yeah go ahead well I don't
know if you have more questions but my
following question is okay so you saw
that in some sort of truc space and then
there's a mapping from Big Space to the
orinal the manifold yeah that's right
yeah and that is you're not losing I no
I mean you go and see uh why don't I
just go and uh just finish up showing
the relationships to the previous
functional Transformations that we have
and the next slide is really talking
about this right and that you can go and
and also really what's going to be
developed on the next couple slides okay
and so let me just go and finish this
and again I'm I'm going to immediately
return to your question okay in in the
like and that uh you also can go and
show that this is effectively log z uh
times a chir pulse okay and that what
Stefan when he tried to bring
in phase in into this ended up going and
replacing the chir pulse with a series
of harmonics and decomposing with
respect to that right he didn't look at
it this way but I'm showing the
connection to the rectifier unit right
and if you only use the leading order
term or the k equals z harmonic you end
up getting down to just the
modulus which is what he implemented in
his scattering transformation okay and
so now let's go on and and really get
into what you're talk what you were
getting at Steve and also what you were
asking about right okay is that uh you
go and you're starting here in terms of
this basically Bono space of all
functionals right okay and this
logarithmic generating functional takes
you down to the Hilbert space of all
possible spectrums right okay and
because of the fact that this is a
logarithmic generating function you're
going to go and find that you're limited
to a fairly
low-dimensional Subspace and in fact the
dimension of that is going to be the
it's going to be uh two times little n
where n is the number of fields okay in
the problem or it's going to be
basically CN so you can do a principal
components analysis on this you'll see
that all of the variation ends up being
in a hyperplane that you can find with a
principal components analysis right and
those directions or those that it's a
set of measures zero right for mhd that
going be showing you little n is seven
there are seven Fields associated with
it right okay
and that uh that when you go and
literally find what these principal
components are each one is going to be a
complex Spectrum we're going to go and
I'll actually show you the example of
where you actually have uh seven complex
spectrums right and if you went through
the normal Wilson procedure and solve
for those spectrums right uh you would
have now the same spectrums okay and so
by making the functional
transformation and then finding the PCA
you find again the basis vectors and
those basis vectors are the
renormalization group equation and you
can project the
original uh Motion in the field domain
okay into a motion in a A in the beta
domain which are the projection into
those little end principle components
that you actually have of the motion
right okay I think you you now realize
that the the coordinates in you know
projected into this which I go and say
are the beta coordinates right are the
reduced order model that or the first
cut at the reduced order model that
you're looking at right okay
but now to go and further understand
what's happening right is that you
actually need to go and find a function
approximator that's needs to go and
approximate a analytic function which is
the complex hamiltonian right and this
actually goes to the second reason why
you like rectified linear units because
this one will now just have a few
singularities in it right the cohomology
classes of of it right okay and uh uh
and I call those the beta stars or all
these beta not Cas right okay which you
can go and also if you're familiar with
Taylor
relaxation in um in uh stellarators for
instance that you go and you'll see that
you energy minimize but you actually go
down to kind of these ground States but
these ground states end up being the
cohomology class uh and are actually the
uh there's a topological obstruction
that you have to go around you can't go
to just sort of zero motion right um and
that I mean it's like you had a a a
topology of a Taurus right if you're
going around either the you know that
you can find that there are a lot of
Loops if you go around the center or you
go around the edge of the donut you
can't go and Shrink that that trajectory
to zero because you're limited by the
topological obstruction of the t2 tourus
and there are two of them you know
obviously with respect to the t2 tourus
associated with it right but those end
up acting as boundary conditions on any
type of analytic function because if you
go and tell me you know the poles and
zeros of the knowing that of an analytic
function in the branch cuts that that's
a boundary condition you solve the ples
equation and that gives you the analytic
function so that knowing the the
effectively poles and zeros the branch
cuts of a function are equivalent to
actually knowing what the analytic
function is right are you saying that um
kind of makes sense to me so have
dynamical system it's got lots of
variables that you know that obey some
complicated equation you're saying
before you take the step of casting it
in this description you have to discover
if there's any underlying non-trivial
topology um and I guess from my
homegrown perspective would you do
that basically by taking Loops you know
on the space and then just trying to see
what Stokes theorem says right isn't
that what it is yeah you can go and do
that but also you can map out I don't
know how often you have to do it but
maybe a lot right but you also Steve can
also map out the trajectories right okay
of it right and you just you just have
to map out little bits of the
trajectories and then go and see how
they and and find and by that you start
you can go and reconstruct the analytic
hamiltonian right okay so how often is
it or maybe you're going to tell us you
know know in a practical example that
you know that whoops you run into a set
of variables that have some kind of
topological instruction or something
like that that you got to fix or or or
drive around or whatever is that is that
a a common event when you have many
variables like that I would think it
might be oh yeah no I mean there aren't
many of them right okay and that also I
mean if you go and bedos also has
another concept he talks about his bars
and stuff
right uh I think forget now what those
acronyms or cheeky things that bed Ro
always comes up with but that he uh goes
and he really talks about why do we keep
on slightly perturbing trajectories and
then integrating them all again in a
very hard way right if we look at nearby
trajectories that you should be
following those nearby trajectories
right okay and what you're looking at
here is that if you're trying to map out
one of these analytic functions right is
that you know you you really can go and
easily interpolate them because analytic
functions are maximally flat right
that's what a solution to lasses
equation is right uh except for uh these
few singularities right that's why
rectified linear units are so good
because when you combine those into a
multi-layer perceptron you get a
piecewise linear function approximator
right which is maximally flat right
except for places where you have a
singularity which means you have a
disconn discontinuity in the first
derivative right okay and that also
tells you why sigmoids are like
spectacularly bad because they are
infinite Ely smooth and they can't
handle the few singularities that you
need but you don't need many of those
tie points right you just need to have
one of the points Beyond The Singularity
and it's very easy for a multi-layer
perceptron to figure out where to put
the cusp and then they go and you'll see
in my example it finds where the cusp is
puts the cusp there and it goes out and
is flat as you go away from there right
okay and it also goes and says that
these things will extrapolate well just
so you're moving away from a singularity
where you've actually sampled it right
because it just goes flat I think John
Field talks about this right but if for
some reason you you're starting to get
into a part of parameter space where
you're walking towards one of these
singularities right you actually see
things are and you don't have it in your
model
you actually see things start getting
worse right okay and that's telling you
that there's an additional Singularity
and you better go and have a you know
start sampling those simulations right
and it can also tell you that is there
actually a beta that's not in your model
right are you missing a term in your
partial differential equations that
you're seeing in the experiment right
but if you actually went and let's say
did the experiment and you actually saw
there was an additional beta in there
that was not actually part of the what
was coming out of your computer
simulations well you actually know what
beta is you know the spectrum of it you
know the spectrum of the partial
differential operator so that you know
that there is a piece of physics you're
missing and you also know what the
spectrum of that partial differential
operator are and that you probably can
go and invert back for what the term is
it will give you large Clues to what the
physics is that you actually don't have
or improperly approximating in your
simulations right okay and I think that
we all know as we start scaling up these
devices the paranoia we have is have we
neglected something that's now going to
become important in the physics right or
is it an extrapolation a way from
well-known singularities in the function
right but you know going and taking a
look at just what these complex
hamiltonians end up being right is that
you can either map out what that
function is or what the uh phase space
looks like what the trajectories look
like or actually what the foliation is
or you can actually go and just know
what those that those Limited number of
singularities are right okay but also
what's the real problem is that here we
have a couple poles and zeros or a
branch cut okay I'll show you an example
of that with a simple analytic function
the Earth foil function right what
happens when you you you know there is a
forward
transformation but also there is an
inverse
transformation okay a well-defined
inverse all right and so that uh what
you're going to go and understand here
is that we're going to go and we're
going to do a forward
transformation into okay this coordinate
system right and then you're going to
want to go and to do predictions or to
find out what to apply to the system if
you're controlling it you're going to
want to do the inverse transformation
okay uh so and I actually more
specifically show that on some other
things right okay but what you're going
to go and see is that we go and we have
this convolutional network and we have
some bottleneck here okay in this case
there's two a little n+ one for energy
and I'll talk about that in a second and
then you actually go and expand it back
out and so that's how you go and you see
that at this point this is the reduced
order model of the system right and I'm
just going and showing things in the
forward sense right okay but what we
actually get into and it's what we the
problem that Ken Wilson had to to
frontally address with respect to
renormalization what is a very simple
poll in this case when you actually go
backwards and go back to the fields
since it's a deep
convolution okay it basically takes this
one pole and spreads it everywhere and
so there are singularities everywhere
you look back in the field domain right
and so what happens in classic
renormalization and what that's actually
doing is taking all of the
singularities and smashing them back
together and collecting them in this
reduced order model space right okay you
have to be careful that you don't
basically throw the baby out in the bath
water because a lot of times people go
and you when they go and solve let say
the Hamilton jacobe equation everybody
loves viscosity
Solutions okay bu or beware you're L2
regularizing all of the singularities
out right they do it because in the
fields you see singularities everywhere
you look you got to get rid of them
right so let's go and L2 regularize and
get rid of all the
singularities unfortunately you're
getting rid of the one Singularity that
you want in the process right because
you're not being careful about it right
and so you know that and it's actually
done all over the place in finance right
it's called interest right is basically
resistivity right L2
regularization and they really destroy
the economy in the process of actually
imposing it physically on the system
because when the FED goes and and Loans
you money at a prime rate they actually
are embedding viscosity into the system
and fundamentally regularizing the
singularities out and Destro they can
destroy the the the Su stable points of
it uh and I'll show you that in a bit or
they can in the like right and so now
let me go and also though too is that
what we're really doing is looking at
things in terms of extended phase space
right okay and that this
hamiltonian is actually this complex
hamiltonian is actually operating on the
extended phase space and I'll talk about
that a bit more in in a bit let me go
back and take another look at what's
happening once we get into these little
q's and P's um I'm G have to wait for
things to update so oh just you know
forgive the one comment I don't know how
long we have the room okay so I you know
would suggest you know bringing things
to a place also where people may have
questions right um because I you know
again I don't know I don't sit up by the
laser but you know we might be kicked
out in five minutes okay I hope
okay well that I'll go and uh skip
forward that's
really okay um let me go and uh skip
forward um to um a u yeah I mean some
Physics examples right and that I mean
what we actually do is and this goes
back to my PhD thesis and it's a motion
guiding Center motion of an
electron uh in a
um uh in a uh strong magnetic
field um and uh you can go and actually
have a moving ion associated with it and
that what you actually go and want to
see here and let me be rather quick
about in terms of the control theory is
that you end up going and seeing that
you actually have associate the electron
you have the O point and you have an X
point which is a saddle point these are
local minimums these are local maximums
on the Saddles you also respect to the
ion have the O point for it and you also
have an X Point okay sitting out here at
Infinity okay and that uh you have what
are either these guiding Center atoms
which are basically an electron bouncing
back and forth on a field line and
slowly e cross be drifting around or you
actually have both the these drifting
pairs which are ions and electrons that
basically are both going around their
cyclotron motion and drifting each other
and you have free ones right okay but
the thing that you actually want and the
point that you'd like to be at you know
in most cases are these inverted
pendulum these maximum local maximum but
they're unstable right and and that
because basically Omega equals zero at
this point and because the mass is equal
to one over Omega squared if I just go
and try to jiggle these things they
don't jiggle if I'm at the point and the
farther I get away from it because the
mass is reduced they go back and forth
more and I jiggle them more that causes
a Ponder mode of stabilization force on
this and that uh and also right here
that I'm sorry
that you probably saw that you can
actually stabilize an invert inverted
Pendulum by jiggling it up and down
right okay associated with it and that
what I think bados is talking about with
Stud pulses is the fact that you can't
just jiggle it anyway they're going to
be in this case you know a few
characteristic spectrums which is a set
of measure zero of however you could
jiggle it and you need to go and jiggle
it with those characteristic spectum DRS
right
okay um I also went and uh went and did
a whole large Ensemble of Gorgon
simulations of uh
magift and uh uh went and did them for
different initial
temperatures uh liner aspect ratios
which is effectively the uh growth rate
of the instability and how aggressive uh
the uh implosion is or the grow rate of
the uh reallyy Taylor
instability and uh because these were uh
2D in the uh uh in the radial direction
and you end up having vorticity
conserved you actually see an inverse
Cascade and these things go and pinch
into a dumbbell and then go out that you
don't have the normal uh regular Cascade
associated with it okay okay and that uh
well you say well in 3D you lose that no
you don't you actually have elicity
magnetic elicity rather than vorticity
in 3D and we actually see you actually
go to basically a dumbbell double helix
is what it looks like in 3D where it
just rotates
around um that I ended up going and
doing a um large number of these
simulations about 539 on RZ
topaz that generated about 100,000 uh
images it took about 200,000 core hours
about two weeks you sitting on the
machine the amount they would give me uh
the training of this workflow which is
what I talked about here I have a log I
have an MST I have a log I have a PCA
and then I have one of these multi-layer
perceptrons with 15 layers in the middle
of it right the training took about 16
GPU hours on my Linux work station to
take the msts and about a day to take
the wavelet phase harmonics but it only
took one course second to find the
principal components and 20 core seconds
to train the multi-layer perceptron
right because it's a very simple
architecture but then I had a surrogate
that actually executed an INT of a core
second and simulates what took 360 cor
hours on the computer to go and simulate
right um and that uh this goes and shows
the uh the the actual simulation versus
the
generated uh of both the density and for
the magnetic field at three different
characteristic times right as the employ
you know the initial condition as the
implosion starts near bang time and
after it's gone and expanded out I you
notice that it preserves also the
correlation between the uh two Fields as
well as many of the details of the of
the simulation yeah so Qui question
really simple back to the picture so so
which is the um Force you know
simulation that is the truth um is it
the one on the left or the right I I'm
sorry it's the one on the left okay
that's that's the truth yeah I'm sorry
for some reason my annotation didn't see
so on the right we're seeing your your
with your method in play your reduced
order model that's the reduc yes that is
exactly right and those are line outs of
the two so you can actually see uh uh
you know the the quantitative
similarities the quantitative right and
then you gave for how long it took to do
the ground truth simulation versus you
know the sort of slick way of of sort of
redoing your variable yeah and that was
3604 hours to tenth of a second okay
yeah what is the actual is it
a uh it's a brilliant liner and uh the
no the the the circle is
buril um and the uh internal part is uh
uh DD so I guess the question is is how
well does the reduce order model do on
macroscopic uh quantities like yield and
things like um yeah we didn't have we
didn't have the physics in there I was
looking at the ability of it to set uh
to do a surrogate on the field so yeah
because I'm yeah and and also to go and
to uh understand the U uh the fact of of
what's actually happening right because
if you go and take a look at the fi2
component right okay that was associated
with the dipole pertubation of the shell
right you actually go and that you go
and you see as you actually come in here
that the strength of this mode uh
increases and you obviously see the
dipole character of it right okay for
the quadripole character you have
actually see it decrease right there
ends up being an inverse Cascade of
energy from here to here okay and we
also are finding in terms of these modes
they actually mean something in terms of
physically what's happening and if I
take a look at you know how one of these
components goes with time that you go
and see now that the actual are the
light curves and the simulated are the
dark curves that that you see that it
finds where the bang time is associated
with this it goes and uh goes and then
fits it linearly puts one of the tie
points on the bang time and then also
does you know puts the the right number
of TI points to follow the curve right
uh it goes and finds the one with the H
largest aspect ratio the most
acceleration com goes and uh you know
goes and hits you know has a shorter
bang time it also goes and shows that as
I go to a higher temperature Adat it
actually doesn't compress as much right
and then also all the systematics are
there I did a feature importance uh uh
in terms of prediction of the profiles
time is the most important well of
course the liner aspect ratio matters a
lot because that determines the
acceleration the next thing that really
matters is the size of the perturbation
but more importantly the angle of it
since it's inverse cascading to the m
equal 2 it matters what the phase is
because it locks on to that and makes it
grow okay but the but you go and see
then okay T not matters but not a lot
because that only matters at stagnation
okay matters how stagnated it gets but
then uh but you know 54 and three don't
matter at all of course not everything's
going into there so you Cascade out of
it so it doesn't really matter how much
53 and five4 but you really see this
thing is now inverse cascading right but
you can actually see that each one of
these modes you know what they are
physically you can make physical
interpretations you know based on it and
really get insight to the fact that
we're getting inverse Cascades a
self-organization right and so if you go
that back down to Sandia now and say
well how are you reaching compression
ratios of 200 to one right we're
self-organized right you know yeah we
get growth of the instability but we
actually self-organize into a dumbbell
and so we don't care how much it grows
because of the self-organization in it
right associated with it this is
actually really controversial uh
actually with respect to the fact that
we were seeing in brce Cascades right
but I think if you really look at these
little tiny mean literally we go and
compress from well they compress at
Sandia on the Z machine from about a
centimeter and they end up getting two
perfect helical threads of 20 microns in
diameter each I mean it's incredible you
know if you look at and you know the
images that they end up having right and
so let me just go and get to the
conclusions here and I mean I welcome
there's a lot I didn't have a chance to
to show you because you were such an
engaged audience early on associated
with this but um what we really have is
a trans transformational method right
that's finding the these time invariant
coordinates right that are really the
solution to the Hamilton jacobe equation
right okay we go from field coordinates
to little
pqs but then when you go and solve for
that you know the that H right and those
trajectories you end up going and
solving for uh what the the the solution
of the Hamilton jacobia equation which
will be big PS big q's and E of P okay
and also by the way the what you
actually are solving for and let me go
and give you uh the punchline and the
answer to a couple different questions
here right if I go and take a look at
the approximate Q function right okay
which is actually normally you go and
say that it's a function of little
Q uh Little P and Theta right okay
that's actually going and if you looked
at it it's actually going and it's
actually Theta of Q and P okay in terms
of that that's actually equal to the
Hamilton's characteristic function or
the action right that's a function of Q
and cap P okay and cap p is actually
what your act is is one of the uh
approximation parameters that you're
dealing with right but this actually is
the action right okay uh in terms of the
solution of the Hamilton jacobia
equation then if you ask what is the
policy which is Little P right okay
that's equal equal to the partial of w
with respect to little Q right okay
which is now a function of little q and
cap P that's actually equal to the
approximate policy of Q and cap P where
this actually normally is just called
the approximation parameter right and
then if I go and find out where the the
um
partial of the energy with respect to
cap P equals zero or that's actually the
angular frequency associated with it
that will actually give me p is equal to
P Stars right then now I'll go and say
that the optimum policy is nothing more
than Q of P
star and the optimum
value ends up up being nothing more than
W of q p Star right and if you now go
and take a look at Deep reinforcement
learning right I've answered a lot of
those questions I posed at the beginning
but it's just simply in the context of
it right and also you're probably aware
of this chasing your tail lack of
independency lack of stationerity right
and what was happening was that as you
go through the iterations in deep Q
learning you're actually tracing things
out and you're converging down to P star
and you're actually the fact that
they're non-stationary is the fact that
P is changing as you're actually moving
to P star and all of this replay
Shenanigans is so that you actually are
approximating W of Q of p and as you're
converging in you're actually track in
out what's actually happening in those
cases right so that you know you go and
find that this is first of all the
revers the reduced order model of
artificial
intelligence I think that what if you
take a look I think it's what generative
pre-trained Transformers or
Transformations are learning they're
learning this
transformation uh I just talked a lot
about you know what's happening in deep
reinforcement learning and you know and
terms of what it's doing here and I have
a lot more detail in the paper uh you
find out what this decoder encoder is
finding it's a solution to the Hamilton
jacobe equation all motion is now
geodesic motion right on this little PQ
space um and that this analytic
hamiltonian is just a solution to lass's
equation and then finally the uh
topology
of the uh low order dimensional manifold
is you're doing a topological Discovery
right um you saw how this has finet
physical meaning and interpretation and
I talked about very early on the
extrapolation and the causal analysis
associated with it uh also that for the
uh uh in terms of the Hamilton you know
the Heisenberg scattering trans
transformation I've called it that
because of its relationship to
Heisenberg's s matrix by the way right
um it's an excellent metric it it
exposes this fundamental underlying
low-dimensional dynamical
manifold uh but also it goes and finally
exposes the fundamental geometrical
objects or these relaxed States or the
singularities or beta Stars these are
the ground states of quantum field
Theory the attractive manifold of
nonlinear Dynamics the emerging
behaviors and self-organizations of
complex systems tailor relaxed States
and bgk modes of plasma physics the plls
and Branch cuts of control theory and
complex analysis but really
fundamentally you're getting at the
homology classes of the topology right
the real fundamental stuff of the
topology and that's actually what's
being learned right your brain at the
very core just goes and finds out what
beta stories are right and from that it
can inverse reconstruct everything
that's happening it can figure out how
to go and control the system right about
these optimal points you know even you
can think about it and you start
thinking in psychological context how do
I control my thoughts to stay in a good
place right you're actually controlling
your your brain that complex system of
your brain to stay around one of those X
points
right that you'd like to go and stay at
rather than going down to one of those
local minimums or that Global minimum of
of mental depression or mental illness
right um and actually mean this in a big
way not a small way right associated
with it I think that there are really
profound uses of this in terms of also
even the understanding of psychology and
uh I'm actually working with some
psychologists Associated uh with the use
of this models so um you know there huge
questions you know going on but that's
really where I said that you know there
are a lot of different places where this
actually comes in and in a way it's a
Smash Up of the learning of of this in
terms of getting to it right and let me
just go and I had one question in the
beginning too in terms of what is Q
learning right what it's learning the
action right but it's also going and
learning that analytic continuation
because the imaginary part of the
hamiltonian is what I would call Cap Q
in terms of the solution that's nothing
more than the partial of the uh of the W
with respect to cap P right and that's
the imaginary part of the hamiltonian
and so by finding W it's actually
finding that complex continuation of the
hamiltonian which are the phase
trajectories or the generator function
of the canonical transformation that
generates the motion is another way of
looking at it so thanks very much thank
you thank our
speaker audience home and abroad you
might say um I have a question that I'm
gonna hold myself back and see if uh
people in the chat or else I'm not sure
how we can see that here have any
questions um uh no we don't don't have
any questions okay looks like a lot of
people were on at different times
yeah okay so they
Canute oh sorry go ahead they can unmute
and ask question okay so well all right
I'll start out with a question then um
so I didn't follow everything but but
but one thing I you know from a again
from a big picture Viewpoint is the
efficiency and also the capturing of
kind of dicey topological singularities
on this
um how much better is it than existing
methods and what kind of problem let's
say you talk about pulse power you know
what kind of physics problem could you
treat that you couldn't do before so you
you gave very impressive numbers for
your system versus I guess I guess a
Brute Force calculation of of of an of
an imploding liner it looked like you
got these sort of semi- Kor things about
writing some nice stuff in those
pictures but being a little aggressive
about about this is where could you go
with this that you could not do before
what what kind of problem in physics
could you solve that you know that was
Impractical
previously um that um I I think that um
the I I
have that the know first of all in terms
of performance as machine learner right
okay that not having to go and train the
uh convolutional networks is absolutely
huge right obviously right I mean the
training becomes trivial you know
associated with it right and that you
know tens of millions of dollar it's Tak
you know it's really tough for Deep Mind
with alha fold Etc I mean they're really
burning large amounts of computer time
associated with that right
okay uh other things in terms of causal
analysis right it goes and gives a
framework right where you can actually
well first of all it gives fast Ser High
High Fidelity uh Cates that go and
conserve all the proper quantities right
when I say High Fidelity that you
conserve those quantities that actually
go to the right emergent behaviors right
okay and don't have the issues of
wandering so far away from the physics
or having effectively numerical
dissipations and the like eventually eat
your lunch okay long term no matter how
high order the the methods are right and
that's absolutely Central to be able to
have uh any type of basian analysis
right or post basian analysis you need a
very fast surrogate associated with it
you need to to 10th of a second
surrogate to be able to go and do that
type analysis so it goes and will go and
and enable that right but also though
too is that I mean I think it's you have
to go and say go supporting causal
analysis is huge because it can go and
start knowing when your data is
Whispering at you that there's going to
be trouble when you scale up your
experiments right and you have ways of
hypoth is testing of are we getting some
new physics and if we actually brought
in that new physics and actually ran it
again with the new physics you know
scaled up you'll start realizing that
some Physics we've been neglecting is
eating your lunch right okay so you can
and and I I think it's an overall I
think challenge I don't think that the
current methods don't support the causal
analysis right because you don't know
what you're getting you don't know what
these variables are in the life right
and you can't go and do those hypothesis
testing of do I have all of the right
directions and are the those directions
in the right direction right associated
with it right and I would be much more
positive with respect to these
singularities right I mean that you know
they aren't like you know painful you
know
uh uh they they aren't painful
annoyances they are the answer right
okay so that you know the uh it's not
that there's something that allows you
to get around no it's something that you
actually that is the answer that you
want to get to I mean it's like
hitchhiker's guy to the Galaxy well I
can tell you the answer but you aren't
going to like it right it's beta Star
right is is what the answer is so the
singularities are
everything and you know I and and don't
and also in terms of
renormalization just
itself that you know this is not you
know where you have to you know have you
know divine inspiration of how to
collect all the
singularities this actually is a
prescriptive way of you do it and it
collects the singularities for you right
so I think in terms of even analytic
renormalization of field theories that
it will on the analytic side give you a
way to go and um get the solution to the
renormalization of the equation right
and also I think a point it's much more
profound to be able to I think it has
real implications about finally unifying
gravity with the other you know field
theories that we have right because I
mean I think that Murray Gelman you know
obviously in his life's work really went
in terms of the quantization of the
particles and Fields of su1 two and
three uh really went and had all those
things but it actually will go and I and
and in in the thinking that I've had I
think this has a real ability to bring
gravity into the fold and put it on a
common ground
with the quantizations that we actually
have in terms of su1 two and three right
which is the enm weak and strong forces
for instance right uh you know the
electron you know electron positrons you
know the nor normal bar Barons and the
uh corpse you may I have a question yeah
sure oh hi Mike this is Milan can you
hear me it's who Milan Milan h
so the question is it seems like we are
trying to find a balance between
stability and accuracy and so usually we
would work with entropy it's like a good
measure and uh so in your framework
could you comment on the sense of
entropy when defining the the topology
of your
manifold if if it's if it's like
meaningful can you put like a number
okay this manifold this entropy and to
so to keep keep the singularities but
keep the dimension low as
well
um that I mean the one thing to go and
um note about this and I I'm I'm I'm GNA
take it on board in terms of the exact
mapping to the part of entropy but the
the thing that you are uh looking at
here as it goes and interacts with the
external systems those are the actual
thermal forces that you know I was going
and looking at and that um there is a um
and I'd have to go and and and uh
um I again I I I really have to think
about that that's a very good question
and uh let me really think I I can't say
offand and I haven't really thought of
what where is entropy and what I'm
talking
about okay thanks I will shoot you an
email okay that that'd be really good if
you could yeah send me an email and I
will uh
respond awesome
thanks well I don't have a question but
I have a comment um you know in in the
perspective of reduced Auto model um a
lot of people just apply the PCA like
soal the Pod
propos um when you do that it's you
don't get the great compression like
compressed solution representation then
you apply that to objection Dom related
problems or you know transport problem
but a lot of you know netive Hy Dynamics
you know they they are driven by
transport yeah yeah so you know people
recently they um started to add a neural
network the reason being is there's a
nonlinear activation function you can
actually you know map in nonlinear fence
so that you don't have to rely on the
linear compression only but I I see your
work have a PCA component and also HST
it's involves with the logarithmic
transformations with the antonium and
then later on layer MLP which also has a
you know rectified l u activation
function I do see that you you have all
the components you know what we do
usually to form a so but in addition to
that training is a lot cheaper than the
the usual neur Network training right
right so I you know yeah I totally agree
that you know that's great Advantage I
myself wanted to apply this
too yeah I think that you said it well
if you go and take a look at what is
here you can go and see how what's here
is is reflected in what's Happ you know
what you've ended up what works right
okay and you can you can see mappings of
this and the structure in the life and
say yeah this is you know I see where
this is happening but it's like but
there are no things to fit basically
right other than the PCA right
associated with it which is a trivial
operation right in the end and that
you're right that they realize it didn't
work right if you're working in the
field domain yeah you see the the huge
HST here in order to be able to get it
into the domain where it is linear right
okay
and but then it's only linear you're
you're confined to this hyperplane right
okay and so it's linear with respect to
the fact you're you're confined to a
linear Subspace but it's far from linear
in that Subspace right it has a very You
Know Rich topology you know in that that
that Subspace but it does it's not so
but but but in the end though it's not
that rich right I mean there only a few
singularities in that Subspace that
determine the whole uh thing around it
right okay and so that you know the you
know in terms of where you normally go
in the convolutional networks right
we're all trying to get down to where
this the space where it is linear okay
and that uh they actually will go and
get it to a space where it's not linear
but it's curved
right okay and then they'll use an MLP
to actually snap it to linear right okay
um and then you know but by construction
they're kind of you know they don't need
to do the PCA anymore right because they
have that nonlinear mapping right so the
convolutional parts of it are just
getting it so it's there but a bit
curved and then they have to go and snap
it but if you've done it correctly it's
already linear so you can just use a PCA
without have they have an MLP at the end
of it right okay but then once you're in
that space and get the projection into
that reduced order model space that
there's another thing of finding out
what the hamiltonian is right because
you need to know what the trajectories
are and that an MLP is great for that
because you know it's single value you
know mean it goes was in single value
but it just has a couple Branch cuts and
singularities and you know an MLP eats
that stuff up right associated with it
so you're right it has those different
the character of the stuff in there but
you know because I know it's a solution
to the Hamilton jacobe equation right
okay and it has the form of that and I
didn't you know have the time to show
this
right is
that I can actually structure a web of
MLPs with specific number of nodes
where I know exactly what that node is
going to be right if I looked at it that
is what what those things are right one
is the action you know the WQ cap P the
other one is ISA P right the other ones
are the C PS another one are the big Q's
right okay and so that you now have gone
and further constrained the network
right to actually match the solution
form of the Hamilton jacobe equation
right but there were cheap ways of doing
this because that and that's what I did
here because if I know this has 15 nodes
then I just have PQ I have some layers
in between right and I just know I need
to have 15 things here right okay so
this is kind of I don't know what's what
they could be add mixtures of each other
right right but when I look at this
structure there's no no doubt about what
things are and so you program this into
tensor flow or you know or pie torch and
you can actually play these nodes out
and those RP right okay associated with
it right and so there's much more
intelligent design into to what this uh
this Hamilton jacobe equation solver is
is
what this is and you know trivially what
the propagator is right in it or you can
also know what the force is in this and
then you transform back out and those
were things I didn't show right this is
how you use this in terms of a surrogate
right oh shoot this is I have to do
stuff the force it here is that uh you
start with initial conditions you apply
the HST PCA and you get the initial
conditions in terms of this you have an
MLP that actually goes and gives you the
P knot Q knots right I now have a
Hamilton jacobia solver which gives me
cap P's Q kns right I now have a
propagator which I know trivially okay
and then I get big key big Q's I go and
have the inverse which gives me Little
P's little Q's I have an MLP that gives
me the output function in p and Q then I
have the inverse transform that actually
gives me the output Fields right that I
end up having right and so that you know
now you have the Lego block right okay
associated with it and you have a very
well constrained Hamilton jacobe
equation and this has absolutely nothing
to learn where normally you're spending
a hundred million dollars to train that
thing right associated with it so and
then you know if I have a controller I
just go and have the Ponder mode of
force here then I just go and give this
and I'll tell you what the force I need
to apply the system in order to
stabilize it right so let me suggest
this some um if there any last minute
questions this would be a good time to
ask them otherwise we're going to
migrate up to your home away from home
upstairs and so that's to remind people
they want to drop by that's building 481
room 2117 not the one in the earlier
messages because the door was locked so
uh but upstairs it should be good and um
you know look forward to and then you
know again I mean if I encourage you to
come by and talk to me you know and the
person with the uh entropy question I
think it'd be great you stop by and we
could actually discuss it and maybe do
some re research real time it' be fine
so let's um yeah I've got a
for want to make sure you get upstairs
okay thank you thank you
everyone I guess we l out very
good thanks for this is very different
but you guys were so engaged